hey guys how are you so I've been
playing this game piano tiles on my
iPhone for a couple of weeks now and
I've got a high score that I am unable
to beat so my best score is in the
classic mode Pro six point two six eight
and so basically you just hit the black
tiles clearly not my best score but
let's see if I can beat it because this
game has been driving me absolutely
insane I use my little pointy fingers
let's see what we can do are you ready
and game play okay that's our I'm
already not gonna win and and we might
as well understand
oh no no good enough no you're stupid
you're stupid
[Music]
no no you're not good enough god why
no it is not my best score
you're so stupid I could punch you in
teeth I'm gonna fix my posture and I'm
gonna freakin beat this I beat my score
[Music]
my level piano big-time I'm not I'm
shaking I'm so not well right now this
game drives me nuts let me know what you
guys is best score is on classic pearl
and I need to go take a nap
[Music]